It's a day these children will remember all
their lives.
For many, it's their first time aboard an
aircraft.
But this plane won't be taking off.
"The flight to nowhere" is an airline with
a difference.
It offers passengers a taste of flying without
ever leaving the ground.
Many schoolchildren here are poor.
Their families cannot afford a real ticket.
The passengers are treated to a full in-flight
experience.
They receive boarding cards, safety briefings.
Even refreshments are served on board.
It's an eye opening experience.
"I've seen planes in the sky.
I used to think they were really small.
But now I know they're actually huge...
"
"I now want to fly to London.
I've heard there are beautiful things to see
in that city."
Some lucky passengers even get to visit the
cockpit.
The man behind the project is Bahadur Chand
Gupta, a retired aircraft engineer.
He sold his land and bought the decommissioned
Airbus A 300 back in 2003 for 600-thousand
rupees – that's about seven thousand euros
— a real bargain.
He charges people according to what they can
afford — as little as a few euro cents or
even nothing at all for the very poor.
"I belong to a very small village.
And, I never expected that I will become an
engineer and I'll be in the airline.
And, people from my village they used to say
we want to see the aircraft and they were
not able to see the aircraft.
And that was the basic idea and basic motivation
that I want to show this aircraft to the poor
people"
"Air travel remains a luxury for many people
in India.
For those, who may never get to take a flight,
this comes close to the real thing without
leaving the ground.
And, it isn't the only place for it in Delhi."
Not far away, a busy main road that runs parallel
to the runway of Delhi's international airport.
It's the perfect spot in the evening to watch
planes land.
Trees double up as chairs.
It's all about getting the right vantage point.
For the poor migrant workers here, shelling
out 4,000 rupees or 50 euros for a cheap flight
ticket is beyond their means.
"It’s my dream to someday take a plane and
fly to my village in Bihar.
But that’s only if I manage to scrape enough
money for a ticket."
Further on, at a railway crossing, regulars
here swear that this is the closest you can
get as the turbojets take off.
"In my village, the planes fly really high
up in the sky.
But from here you can see them up close.
It's an amazing feeling."
"We may not have the money for a plane ticket.
But that doesn't stop us from dreaming about
what it must feel like to be up in the sky."
Back at the flight to nowhere, passengers
simulate an evacuation to finish the experience.
Rarely has an emergency situation seemed like
so much fun.